SLAMMED DOWN, MAJOR DOWN.S.
WEST PALM BEACH, FLORIDA.hn: TH
IT IS SO NICE HAVING GUYS WITH
THAT KIND OF LINK. COFFEY.
BUT NO HELP IS THERE
A SMALL BEAT. THOMPSON WITH A T.
I WASN'T SURE WHAT YOUACH.
COACH, WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO O
>> Eric: MY SHOT?
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BLOCK OU'R
ATTACKING THE RIM BABY.BALL TO
>>
NO ONE THERE  CEDI OSMAN.
BAZL
THERE IS THE CONTACT.
AND THEN HE  T MY
GOODNESS.
LAURI MARKKANEN WITH A DUNKS.
FIRST LAURI MARKKANEN.
PATTY MILLS TO MAKE HIM SEE
BODIES IN FRONT OF BOUNDS.
>> Mark: HOW HIGH BLAZERS
HAD TO PUT ON
>> Stan: JEFF GREEN HERENINE HA.
LIKE A HAD GONE OFF, BUT
THEY WENT BACK AND REVIEWED IT.
CORN BREAD AND OH, TRANSITION.
>> Mark: WOW.
BREATH
>> Matt: BARNES, LEADS THE
SHE ACTUALLY GOT UP AND JUST
WAVED TO